y
[Música]
nuevo escándalo por vacunaciones de
privilegio contra el joven 19 en américa
del sur primero fue perú con su vacuna
gate y ahora es argentina con sus
vacunas vía de picnic que llevó a la
dimisión del ministro de salud tras
conocerse que varias personas cercanas
al gobierno se inocularon antes del
inicio de la campaña de inmunización
en rusia el tribunal de moscú rechazó la
apelación de la sentencia del líder
opositor alexéi navalni y ratificó la
pena suspendida de 3.5 años de prisión
en un juicio calificado de arbitrario
por el tribunal europeo de derechos
humanos sin embargo la justicia cortó su
condena original por el tiempo que ya
había pasado bajo arresto domiciliario
miles de personas en mianmar continúan
manifestándose en contra del golpe
militar del primero de febrero y exigen
la liberación de la líder derrocado ha
usado su chip rechazan la muerte de una
joven que fue herida de bala tras
autoridades durante una de las protestas
según fuentes médicas hoy seis personas
han resultado heridas de bala
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 soy re blanco como
siempre un gusto saludarlos el escándalo
de las vacunaciones irregulares en las
cúpulas del poder en américa latina no
para luego de conocerse el vacuna gate
en perú que ha llevado a la dimisión de
altos funcionarios del gobierno se
destapó en argentina el llamado vacunas
vip y que llevó a renunciar al ministro
de salud después de que se conocieran
que algunas personas de su entorno
fueron vacunadas sin respetar los turnos
establecidos
carla vizzotti será la nueva encargada
de la salud del país y asumirá el cargo
y sábado veamos el informe de juán
pupiales
un escándalo en medio de un momento
clave coincidiendo con los primeros días
de la vacunación para mayores de 70 años
se conoció que personas cercanas al ya
ex ministro de salud ginés gonzález
garcía han recibido un trato
privilegiado y se han saltado los turnos
para acceder al antídoto un periodista
cercano al ejecutivo destapó lo que se
ha denominado como vacunación villa y
una situación que llevó al presidente
alberto fernández a pedir la renuncia de
gonzález quien dimitió no sin antes
explicar que las personas vacunadas
pertenecían a los grupos competentes y
mencionando también una confusión
involuntaria la mentalidad sinceramente
que semejante malentendido pudiera
deslucir una gestión que dio un fuerte
impulso a la reconstrucción del sistema
de salud
gonzález garcía ya había sido el
ministro de salud a comienzos del 2010
estuvo en el cargo desde el comienzo de
la pandemia destacando por conseguir que
argentina se convirtiera en el primer
país de américa en usar la vacuna rusa
sputnik
según datos del jueves argentina había
administrado más de 635.000 dosis lo que
equivale al 1 41 por ciento de su
población
tras lo vivido en perú con un escándalo
de cientos de altos funcionarios
vacunados de manera privilegiada el
fantasma de una situación similar se
extiende sobre argentina aunque de
momento a diferencia de perú todo parece
indicar que en este caso el presidente
fernández no estaba al tanto de lo que
ocurría en el ministerio de salud
un estudio del hospital israelí seva
publicado en la revista científica the
lancet reveló que la primera dosis de la
vacuna producida por facer disminuyó en
un 75 por ciento de las infecciones de
coronavirus al menos dos semanas después
de su administración para hablar sobre
el éxito del proceso de vacunación en
israel quiero saludar en este momento a
alejandro rosental jefe de la unidad de
cirugía maxilofacial del hospital shift
de la ciudad de safet e instituto
clínico de la facultad de medicina de
bar-ilán university en israel doctor
gracias por estar aquí con nosotros en
france 24 le pregunto a qué se debe el
éxito de este proceso de inmunización
masiva en israel y que reveló
exactamente el estudio de facer
qué tal cómo están
bueno acá vamos
el éxito s viene a hacer que la
el primer ministro de israel cuando
empezó la pandemia ella apostó con las
vacunas de pfizer y de modernas pero más
con la de facer y se comprometió en
adquirir estas vacunas ya desde el
principio al principio cuando empezó la
pandemia y llegamos a hacer un acuerdo
muy importante con facer e israel que
ésta es un país relativamente pequeño y
muy bien organizado tiene 9 millones de
habitantes y ya en el término de dos
meses más o menos ella ha vacunado
prácticamente a 50% de la población sea
hemos recibido ya unas seis millones de
dosis en más de seis millones de dosis
hay más de cuatro millones 250 mil
personas vacunadas con la primera dosis
y casi tres millones de personas con la
segunda dosis o sea que el sistema
e israelí es el sistema que está muy
bien organizado con sistemas de
administradores sociales que están que
ocurren un 100 por ciento de la
población es un sistema social que su
sistema gratis que lo tiene toda la
población y eso permitió a extraer al
sistema de salud poder distribuir las
vacunas de forma muy precisa y muy
sistemática a toda la población en tener
los resultados al día y al minuto doctor
de lo que está uno en todo el país
doctor y le pregunta entonces cuál ha
sido su experiencia durante este proceso
de vacunación tengo entendido que usted
ya se vacunó
la experiencia es muy buena lo estamos
viendo que prácticamente no hay enfermos
que nuevos que han pasado
se han vacunado prácticamente un 0.4 por
ciento de los de la gente que se ha
vacunado se ha infectado en realidad
prácticamente nadie que de los que se ha
vacunado yo recibí las dos dosis en las
tres semanas de diferencia y la
respuesta a las de la segunda dosis
estuvo un par de días un poco como
afiebrado un poquito con con debilidad
como una gripe normal un par de días
pero por supuesto que vale vale el hecho
de estar vacunado y poder seguir
atendiendo a la gente y debido a este
éxito el gobierno mañana va a relajar
estas medidas de confinamiento doctor le
pregunto si esto entonces no puede
suponer un retroceso en lograr la
inmunidad de rebaño en ese territorio
bueno evidentemente la inmunidad de baño
va a ser muy difícil cuando israel tiene
un gran porcentaje de niños de medio 16
años que personas un 30% de la población
o sea que vamos a poder tener máximo tal
vez un 70% la gente vacunada por ahora
pero igualmente es complicado porque
estamos tratando de abrir el comercio en
forma muy medida
por supuesto que la gente que se va no
recibe a la semana por eso ya recibir
por ejemplo el certificado de vacunación
lo que se llama el pasaporte verde que
nos va a permitir en poder entrar eso
como decías ahora los por ejemplo de los
shopping los negocios que van a tener el
permiso
el certificado verde como se le dice en
arba entonces va a poder entrar
solamente gente que tenga ese pasaporte
verde porque aparte de todas las medidas
de distanciamiento y higiénicas por
supuesto sí doctor gracias por su tiempo
por estar con nosotros en france 24
vamos a estar russian de un tribunal de
moscú rechazó la apelación del líder de
la oposición acceden a bani contra su
sentencia de prisión previamente
conversamos con nuestro corresponsal en
la capital rusa xavier colás que nos
contó que supone esta confirmación de la
condena esto fue lo conocido
pues supone que no haber clemencia para
alexéi navalni era una esperanza que
aunque pequeña existía en algunos
ámbitos de la oposición entre otras
cosas por lo que había ocurrido en el
pasado lo cierto es que hasta la fecha
las autoridades descubrió a la justicia
rusa siempre habían evitado que alexéi
navalni un carismático líder de la
disidencia rusa pasase largas temporadas
en prisión tal vez por el miedo a que su
popularidad creciese pero esta vez no ha
habido en marcha atrás y aleccionaban me
parece que va a tener que pasar dos años
y medio en una prisión que todavía no se
ha determinado puesto que sigue en un
centro de detención preventiva porque
tiene todavía un juicio pendiente en el
cual tendrá que responder hoy por cierto
en mi el mar miles de personas siguen
manifestándose en varias ciudades del
país exigiendo la liberación de la
libertad roca dance and such y así como
por la muerte de una joven que fue
herida de bala días atrás por las
autoridades cuando participaba en una de
estas protestas este sábado se han
registrado seis heridos de bala mientras
autoridades expresaban a los
manifestantes informe andrew amaya
un minuto de silencio por mí a tweetdeck
in miles de birmanos rindieron homenaje
a la joven de 20 años que perdió la vida
por un disparo en la cabeza y que ahora
se ha vuelto en un símbolo para los
manifestantes en pro de la democracia no
hay posibilidades de que muchas más
personas mueran nosotros mismos ni
siquiera podemos saber si moriremos o no
pero tenemos que luchar hasta el final
independientemente de nuestras vidas por
un éxito que llegará después podemos
deshacernos de esta dictadura militar
son muchos los que siguen uniéndose a la
campaña de desobediencia civil en
protesta contra el golpe militar del
pasado primero de febrero que derrocó la
líder del país en sanssouci y a otros
funcionarios
[Aplausos]
los manifestantes exigen la restauración
del gobierno electo la liberación de
sushi y la eliminación de la
constitución de 2008 redactada bajo la
supervisión militar y que otorga al
ejército un papel importante en la
política de mianmar
13 los militares dijeron que gobernarían
democráticamente pero al mismo tiempo
cortaron la conexión a internet y
bloquearon plataformas de redes sociales
como facebook y twitter
eso significa que sus palabras no
coinciden con sus acciones por lo tanto
nunca les creeremos y la comunidad
internacional ha condenado el uso de la
fuerza contra manifestantes y las
detenciones que ya suman casi 550 en
menos de tres semanas entre ellos
líderes políticos funcionarios monjes y
activistas
las protestas continúan en españa por
cuarto día consecutivo tras el
encarcelamiento del rapero pablo hasél
acusado de enaltecimiento al terrorismo
y por publicar vídeos que incitaban a la
violencia en twitter veamos el informe
cuarta noche de protestas en españa a
medida que los manifestantes siguen
luchando por la libertad de expresión en
el país la violencia nocturna se desató
desde el inicio de las protestas el
martes en respuesta a la sentencia del
rapero pablo hasél condenado a nueve
meses de prisión por publicar trinos que
según las autoridades enaltecían al
terrorismo
la condena dividió la población y
también al gobierno de coalición con
algunos miembros del ejecutivo a favor
de los manifestantes existe además un
amplio consenso dentro de la sociedad
española para amparar mejor la libertad
de expresión en línea con la regulación
que existe en otros países europeos y el
gobierno de españa ya ha manifestado que
va a mejorar la protección legal de la
libertad de expresión en segundo lugar
en una democracia plena y la democracia
española es una democracia plena resulta
inadmisible el uso de cualquier tipo de
violencia no hay excepción a esta regla
no hay causa ni lugar ni situación que
pueda justificar el uso de la violencia
el viernes el presidente pedro sánchez
dijo que el uso de la violencia
se puede justificar la semana pasada el
gobierno anunció que cambiaría la ley
para garantizar el derecho a la libertad
de expresión y eliminar eventuales penas
de cárcel no obstante este cambio
llegaría tarde para la sentencia de
hazel por lo que algunos socios de la
coalición del presidente sánchez
firmaron una petición de indulto para el
rapero encarcelado
una dura y mortal tormenta infernales
continúa arrasando el sur de eeuu con
texas como principal afectado millones
de personas vivieron sin energía durante
días en medio de temperaturas bajo cero
y aunque la frágil red eléctrica regresa
poco a poco la interrupción del servicio
de agua fue la constante de este viernes
una crisis energética que se ha
convertido en una crisis de recursos
hídricos esta residente de houston no
tuvo energía en casa durante cuatro días
y ahora se ha quedado sin agua las
gélidas temperaturas provocaron que se
congelarán las cañerías de su casa de
gstaad stroud cuando acabo de tener un
derrame así que ya sabes cuando dicen
que la electricidad sufrirá
fluctuaciones que vendrá y se irá
nosotros nunca lo vimos nunca tuvimos
dos en torno a 14 millones de personas
cerca de la mitad de habitantes de texas
están sufriendo problemas de agua muchos
no tienen agua de llave y algunos de los
que si la tienen están siendo avisados
de hervirla después de que las plantas
de tratamiento de agua se quedaran sin
energía y otros tienen que tratar con
tuberías rotas e inundaciones con los
estantes de los comercios vacíos
millones de personas dependen de lugares
de distribución como este yo despierto
desde las 5 y he estado en la carretera
desde las 6 y sé que son las once y
media pero me voy a quedar sentado aquí
no tengo otra opción todas las tiendas
de mi zona se quedaron sin agua
de agua es sólo el último de una cascada
de problemas en texas la inusual
tormenta invernal causó la crisis en el
estado
apagando muchas de las redes eléctricas
y dejando a millones sin calefacción
durante días bajo temperaturas heladoras
mientras se espera que las temperaturas
suban este fin de semana el enfado es
alto entre la opinión pública los
funcionarios locales intentan
tranquilizar a la población esta semana
pasada ha sido un gran reto quizás como
ningún otro reto que hayamos enfrentado
hasta ahora continuaremos trabajando
para abordar y encontrar sus necesidades
y retos para ayudarles a superar el
presidente estadounidense joe biden dijo
el viernes que aprobará la declaración
de desastre en texas allanando el camino
para más ayuda
hasta aquí el informativo continua con
nosotros
[Música]
r efe y france 24